حيث يلتقي وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير
فيصل بن فرحان بنظير الروسي
في موسكو في جلسه مباحثات بين الوفدين
السعوديه والروسي التي ستبحث العلاقات
السعوديه الروسيه اضافه الى الازمه
الاوكرانيه التي هذه الزياره بعد زياره
ايضا قام بها الوزير السعودي للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه
نحن مرتاحين جدا بمستوى العلاقات الروسيه
والسعوديه
ونعتبر ان تطوير هذه العلاقات من
الاولويات لانا ونحن نقوم بكل ما يلزم لي
التحقيق وتنفيذ الاتفاقيات التي
تم وصول اليها على مستوى قاده بلدين
بنفخمه الرئيس لديمير بوتين وجلاله الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز ولي العهده محمد بن
سلمان
المهم ان هناك التنسيق الدائم متبادل على
المستوى الوزارات والعياءات الحكوميه
المعانيه وقبل كل شيء في مجال والقطاعات
تجاره والاقتاد والاستثمارات وهناك التوصل
الدائم على هذا المستوى ونت
الخطوات اللازمه لتطوير التعاوننا
[موسيقى]
ونحن نرحب بزياده اهتمام المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
للمشاركه بشكل نشاط ليس فقط في التسويه
القضايا الاقليميه ولكن كمان القضايا على
مستوى الدولي نابولي
واكيد يعني نتعامل بشكل وثيق في كل هذا
المصائل وانا عامل في ان اليوم نحن نتفق
على الخطوات القادمه
لمنفع تسويه كل هذا الامور
ارحب بكم من جديد
شكرا جزيلا
علي صديقي
اشكركم على كرم الضيافه وحفاوه الاستقبال
سواء فيما يتعلق بتنميه العلاقات المشتركه
او التنسيق لمواجهه التحديات الدوليه هي
كان
يشنوه
تطوردينات
على ارضيه من التاريخ الممتد لعلاقه
متميزه بين بلدينا ونتطلع عند اسهم
مباحثاتنا اليوم
في البلدين في توحيد الرؤى ودعم العلاقات
الثنائيه لمجالات ارحب وفقا لتوجيات قياده
البلديه
لمعاليكم على حسن الضيافه وكرب استقبال
ونتطلع اجتماعنا النتائج تحققت التطلعات
ان شاء الله